في أعماق بلاد الذهب في السودان ،
يكدح عمال المناجم في الحرارة الحارقة
بالكاد نجوا في ما ينبغي أن يكون واحدًا
من أغنى دول إفريقيا التي
توفر الذهب للحرب في قارة
بعيدة ،
نحقق في قوة أقوى
من حكومة السودان التي تتحكم في
الذهب الذي يفسد مصير السودان ويهددني ومصادرنا
وإحباط الديمقراطية للتهرب من
العقوبات في حرب روسيا على أوكرانيا ،
المدير الروسي في طريقه ويقولون
إننا اكتشفنا مدى سيطرة روسيا
على السودان
[الموسيقى]
لآلاف السنين أنتج السودان بعضًا
من الذهب الأكثر رواجًا في العالم
وجيش بوتين الخاص
تعرف مجموعة فاجنر شبه العسكرية سيئة السمعة أن
حكومة السودان تنكر
وجود فاغنر في البلاد
ولكننا لا نشتريها وقد توصلنا إلى التحقيق
في مخالب واغنر الممتدة عبر
إفريقيا ، واكتشفنا أن بعض أكثر
عملائها شهرة يعملون في
السودان.  أفغاني براغ محيط
رأس واغنر ميخائيل
باتوبكين بروغوتيان رئيس العمليات السودانية والإسكندرية  er
sirkovich kuznetsov wagner رئيس تنفيذي
أدين سابقًا
بالاختطاف والسرقة بالعمل مع هذا الرجل
الجنرال السوداني محمد حمدان ديغالون
المعروف أيضًا باسم hemetic في مقايضة
للتدريب والأسلحة ،
نسافر 200 ميل شمالًا من
العاصمة هارتونغ إلى بلد الذهب
لإلقاء نظرة فاحصة على  يعمل عمال مناجم الذهب الحرفيون الرئيسيون في واغنر على
إحضار الصخور التي يستخرجونها هنا
لتتم معالجتها
، حيث يتم إنتاج 85 من ذهب السودان
حرفيًا
هنا ، وقد لا يبدو كثيرًا
هذا ما تبقى بعد أن يتم طحن الصخور
التي جلبها عمال المناجم
الآن.  أخذوا ما في وسعهم
منه ولكن
يتم بيع هذا
، وعندما يتم معالجته بشكل صحيح
مع شخص لديه تقنية فائقة ،
يمكنك جني عشرة أضعاف ما يكسبه عمال
المناجم هناك
بعشرة أضعاف دون أي من
الأعمال الشاقة
والأجنبي الوحيد  مصنع المعالجة الذي
يعمل في السودان هو الذهب المميز لفاغنر
على الرغم من أن القانون السوداني الذي يقصر
الملكية على السكان المحليين يثير القلق أيضًا
تم فرض عقوبات على الذهب منذ عامين من قبل
الولايات المتحدة لاستغلال
موارد السودان الطبيعية ونشر
نفوذها الخبيث في جميع أنحاء العالم
وفقًا للحكومة السودانية
التي أوقفت عملياتها رسميًا
لكنهم ما زالوا هنا يتهربون من
العقوبات ، وقد
تحققنا من موقعهم
بالإحداثيات التي قدمها السودانيون
محققو مكافحة الفساد
ونتوجه إلى هناك لنرى بأنفسنا
بينما نقترب من العلم الأحمر
للاتحاد السوفياتي السابق ينفجر في مهب الريح الذي
يستخدمه القوميون الروس بشكل متزايد ،
فإنه يشير بوقاحة إلى
مركب marui Gold الذي تجلس فيه ناقلة روسية بجواره
نصل إلى المدخل  وقرر
طرح بعض الأسئلة ولكن ليس قبل
تشغيل الكاميرات السرية لدينا
بشكل جيد ، وهذا مناسب ، لقد أكدوا للتو
أن الروس في هذا
الموقع ،
هناك
سيارة بيك آب سوداء تقترب من
الرجال الذين أكدوا للتو أن المدير الروسي
موجود في تلك السيارة السوداء وهو كذلك
في طريقه إلينا
، تتسابق شاحنة روسية إلى المكتب ولكن لا
يبدو أن أحدًا كوميديًا
يبدو أن المدير الروسي قد غير
رأيه ،
لكن آخرين يحضرون بدلاً من ذلك
يزعمون أن هذا المصنع مملوك للسودانيين
ويسمى
تذكر هذا الاسم ، من المهم أن
نخرج مكان الإقامة للقيام ببعض
التصوير ولكننا نتبع
الأساليب الأمنية التي يريدونها  علينا أن نوقف هذه
الأرضية العامة ،
فهذه أرضية عامة ، لماذا توقف الساتر الترابي الخاص بك
هنا في
محاولة لحملنا على المضي قدمًا في
التقاط صور لنا من
لوحات ترخيصنا
، والسبب في أنهم متوترون جدًا هو أيضًا
واجهة للشركة الروسية  ماروي جولد
فاغنر لا تزال تعمل بشكل غير قانوني
شركة أجنبية تتظاهر بأنها
سودانية للتهرب من عقوبات الولايات المتحدة ،
نحصل على وثائق التسجيل الخاصة بهم
لإثبات
ذلك ، الوثيقة الموجودة على اليسار هي
لماروي جولد ، تلك الموجودة على اليمين ، هذه
التواريخ تمثل الشكاوى المقدمة في
محاكم العمل  ضد marui gold
هؤلاء من الصلاج هم نفسهم
بموجب القانون السوداني عندما
يتم نقل ممتلكات الشركة ، لذا فهل هناك أي
أحكام ضدها هنا يمكنك أن ترى
الأحكام الإلكترونية ضد الشركتين
متطابقة ،
كل ما فعلوه هو تغيير اسم
واغنر الذي يختبئ على مرأى من الجميع لتجنب
عقوبات الولايات المتحدة والحفاظ على
تدفق خط الأنابيب المالي مرة أخرى إلى موسكو
وحربها على أوكرانيا
عمل خطير يجب الخوض فيه
منذ وصولنا  في البلد ، لقد
أبلغتني مصادر التهديدات التي
يعتقدون أنها ذات مصداقية ضدي
يقولون إن هذا ما يحدث هنا عندما
تنظر عن كثب إلى المعاملات التجارية لروسيا ،
نحن في طريقنا لمقابلة أحد هذه
المصادر وطلب مني القدوم  على طول
ميراوا للذهب هي واجهة للروس
تحديدا لقوى واغنر
التي تعمل على استغلال الذهب في
السودان وتصديره
فهي واجهة ليست شركة
تستخرج الذهب من المخلفات وتشتري
الذهب من عمال المناجم الحرفيين السودانيين
وهذا غير قانوني  لأن القانون ينص على
أنه من المفترض أن يقوم أي منتج للذهب
بالإبلاغ عن الكمية التي ينتجها
للبنك المركزي ووزارة
التعدين وهذا لا يحدث
داخل السودان.  قام البنك المركزي
بالتقاط هذه الصورة لشاشة كمبيوتر
تظهر الإنتاج الرسمي في عام 2021 عند
49.7 طنًا ، و
32.7 طنًا غير معروف من قبل
البنك المركزي ،
لكن الرقم الحقيقي الذي أخبرنا به
المبلغون عن المخالفات قد يكون أكثر من 220 طنًا
أي حوالي 13.4 مليار دولار
من الذهب في العام الذي سُرِق من
السودان ،
كيف حدث هذا
قبل عامين ، لقد نجح الناس في
الإطاحة بثاني أطول ديكتاتور حاكم في إفريقيا بعد
18 شهرًا ، حيث قام الجيش
بانقلاب خاص به
طار حكمًا مدنيًا ، وقد
فعلوا ذلك.
دعم مقابل الذهب ، كان
لهذا الرجل مقعد في الصف
الأول لمكائد روسيا ولديه
أدلة تثبت أنه سيكسب من خلال دعم
انقلاب الجيش السوداني تحت
التهديد بالاغتيال الذي كان
مختبئًا به طوال الأشهر التسعة الماضية وهو ينتقل
من منزل آمن إلى منزل آمن
اعتبر الضباط الروس والسودانيون
المدنيين في الحكومة
عقبة أمام خطتهم الرسمية
لم تكن فرقة عمل مكافحة الفساد
تستسلم للضغوط أو التهديدات أو حتى الرشوة
، فقد وجد أن القوات المسلحة
متواطئة في تهريب الذهب من
قبل الروس وقد أثيرت معهم
هل تلوم روسيا على موت
الديمقراطية هنا في السودان  من المؤكد أن
روسيا تتحمل غالبية اللوم
على استمرار ولادة الديمقراطية في السودان
بعد أيام قليلة فقط من مقتل ابن أخيه على يد
جهات حكومية تحاول وقف
مظاهرة مؤيدة للديمقراطية
في الأسبوعين اللذين قضينا فيهما في السودان
نحقق في تعدين الذهب غير القانوني في روسيا
10 أشخاص  قُتلوا احتجاجًا من
أجل التغيير
، فليس فقط في ساحات القتال في
أوكرانيا أن روسيا تراق الدماء
هنا أيضًا ، فهناك تكلفة بشرية
تكلفة دعم روسيا
لجنرالات السودان مقابل الذهب
cnn
sudan
b
you